Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
has urged NATO members to guarantee the
protection of Ukraine's nuclear
facilities over the weekend zapparesia
power plant came under Fire with the
United Nations Atomic body warning the
Russia and Ukraine are playing with fire
oh we can get more on the situation uh
on the ground with the former senior
military intelligence and security
officer Philip Ingram Phillip good to
see you um let's start by talking about
nuclear power plants in Ukraine and
we've heard a lot about zapparesia it's
been under attack numerous times just
how practical would it be for NATO
members to protect the likes of
zapparesia it's a good call but totally
impractical because if we put NATO
troops on the ground they have to
protect themselves we don't know who
shelled in whether it was the Russians
the Russians accused the ukrainians
um and instantly it would bring NATO
troops into direct conflict
um in in in in this Russian special
military operation or the Ukrainian war
and that can't happen because that would
be the start of a wider European
conflict if not world war three what is
it we're looking at here so what we're
looking at here is this is Russian mod
um footage they're claiming these are
the attacks
um by the ukrainians onto the zapparisha
nuclear power plant it hasn't been
verified and the Russian minister of
defense is also known as the ministry of
disinformation in reality when we look
at what they put out the ukrainians
haven't really made a statement on this
but this after this came out this is
when President zielinski called for NATO
to protect the area of the nuclear power
plant it's all part of it makes no sense
for Ukraine to attack it the potential
environmental runoff of an accident
happening there especially with the
Juniper River would go on for many years
after this conflicts finished it would
fit in with the Russians trying to get a
false flag incident to continue to put
nuclear Terror on and pressure on
Ukrainian people on the on wider Europe
and to continue to fight the the energy
War they're doing inside Ukraine and
with Europe
protection from NATO member countries
that remains a very worrying situation
and let's talk about fighting in the
donbass region it continues what update
can you give us it does continue we've
had the Russian troops move back from
Harrison as they they give the grant to
the ukrainians the Russian troops have
refurbished just from there and have now
moved up into the donesque Bak muta area
where the Russians for a number of weeks
now I've been trying to prosecute
operations and attack forward they
haven't achieved very much they want to
try and capture the whole of the
donesque or blast and so that Putin can
have some form of success it's not
really going to happen they've also
moved some of the troops up a little bit
further north of trump block any
potential Ukrainian move through the
Salvatore V criminal line I'm cut in an
attack down into the Russian areas from
the north there
um that road is very important because
it's one of a number of Roads or lines
of communication that are linking Russia
through into where the Russian troops
are and everything else is needed to get
ammunition ends need to get people in
need to get equipment in uh and the UK
minister of defense this morning said
that Russia is suffering severe
shortages of Munitions and skilled
Personnel that's a very strong statement
and if Russia is running out of
ammunition
um that gives the ukrainians a more
impetus for them to continue with the
momentum they've got already
um we haven't mentioned the prospect of
them in a while but peace talks are
being talked about again I mean it's
been such a rocky road hasn't it so far
at the beginning of this conflict uh
there was sort of back Channel talks
going on and some high profile talks in
turkey and now what's happening what's
the prospect of them they'll always be
back tunnel talks going on um this is
this conflict's only ever going to end
with diplomacy however
president zielinski the ukrainians have
got the momentum at the moment they're
setting the conditions um and actually
the only acceptable
um uh peace settlement for the
ukrainians will be the restoration of
the pre-2014 international boundaries
Russia will not want to go that far back
so they'll keep pushing no
um for peace for a time to try and get a
ceasefire to consolidate what's going on
in rebuild their forces again president
zielinski doesn't need to do that but he
does need to keep talking diplomacy to
the International Community Philip thank
you Philip Ingram with the latest there
on Ukraine we'll speak to you throughout
the program thank you very much for the
update